when they dreamed of Europe ensuring
looked nothing like this the refugee
camp in lesbos is grim and it is getting
worse with the weather anyone arriving
now has to sleep on waterlogged ground
in tents blown apart by the wind there
are only a few staff here to process
thousands of refugees they're doing
their best but they're overwhelmed by
the numbers a hand white and wrinkled
from the cold and rain clings to a fence
so he doesn't lose his spot in the queue
four right and four on their brain
behind of desert for night and for day
an English volunteer from Manchester
shouts to the crowd trying to get them
in order the great police are saying
they must sit down before any are
allowed through the gates but the paths
underneath them are flooded and nobody
wants to sit in that the police put on
their riot gear and get ready to open
the gate to let just 20 select people
through one man collapses unconscious
he's rushed to see the doctor
I'm later told he survived that he was
lucky
occasionally the sheer weight of people
forces the gates open there's a
momentary rush to get in a bit of panic
and then settles back down again
those that haven't made it through this
time go back to patiently waiting in the
rain huddled under their sodden blankets
a man takes off his shoe and shows us
his steaming wrinkled foot
he has trench hood and needs to see a
doctor he isn't the only one fires lit
under tarpaulins keep them warm but not
drunk many people like this woman asked
us for help or anything we could
it is truly desperate here and according
to the aid workers I spoke to privately
it is getting worse and it is on the
point of a crisis the winter will be
very tough
Alistair bug on Sky News lesbos